hello we are live and immediately as
soon as we went live Harris started off
um I'm loving your shirt today Harris
that is absolutely stunning well done so
I designed that
um good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and Movie Channel and if I'm
talking quickly it's because I've
literally ran up to a computer on and
gone go because I got the time wrong I'm
sorry I got a really bad head as well oh
man but anyway so today guys we are
going to be talking about the Stargate
movie and what we would like to see but
obviously first of all we've got to do
the uh uh
[Music]
all right
because it's Stargate live Sunday for
three weeks in a row guys we're doing
really well
um I feel very organized so right
obviously we've heard this news but I've
got a little bit of an update for you so
my phone rang at um two o'clock in the
morning Saturday morning Friday night
Saturday morning
so I answered the phone
and um I went who's dead somebody might
be dead finding me at three o'clock in
the morning somebody better be dead
um and then I got a voice and now
um Matt you you'll know who I mean it's
the person that's normally emails us
that actually works at MGM not the other
one so I got this phone call and and
they're chatted away to me [__] I'm so
sorry I forgot about the time difference
and they've actually they've had a
couple of drinks after work so it was
like eight o'clock in America so it was
like
three o'clock here and I was just like
oh thank you so much for that but anyway
I then panicked because I thought their
phoning me it must be that MGM has
discovered them you know like and and
covered this but I started to stress
thinking oh Jesus them they know who
they are and they've been sacked right
but they haven't they were phoning me
because
um they've had several meetings through
the week and apparently this plan of
Jennifer salkeys to do a movie has gone
down like a lead balloon and and we
talked about it beforehand that it
seemed to be that everyone else wanted
to do a series but Jennifer sulky was
like no movie movie movie
um and we've got all this money that
Amazon want to do cinematic releases and
one of them is going to be them Stargate
so all the people Executives who've ever
started talking and apparently this has
really gone down badly at MGM they
really don't like it so um they did an
internal survey you know like what we
did do you want to move it or do you
want a TV show and apparently they asked
um 5 000 plus people somewhere
um and and Survey did this survey
um and the basically answer was very
similar to ours it was something like 80
something percent of my TV series and
don't want a movie
um and the one question apparently they
did like a bunch of different questions
but one of them was do you want a movie
at all and a bunch of people said no and
my signals rubbish in it can you see me
right
yes
that's not great a little bit jittery
but you're alright okay
um
sorry oh such a bad head
it feels like there's a knitting needle
sticking in the back of my head there
and then my temple there so at any point
I just go
that's why okay
um do you have an aspirin or an Excedrin
nearby
no I haven't took anything what was that
last one an Excedrin
we don't get that oh those are the best
because that that should
it's gone we have paracetamol aspirin
and ibuprofen and that's basically it
'll leave
no no in the U.S you know we've got 70
different types of pills for each little
thing you could have you know
when we were in New York my wife had um
uh she was really not well with the flu
and we got this stuff and we were like
looking for a lamp sit basically it was
like we don't know any of these drugs
names don't know what any of them are
um and then um she found this stuff and
it was just amazing it's like she felt
better almost instantly and um but when
we got back we're like what were we
taking
clue hell you know however I know
[Music]
you you think we're great because we
just have so many options of random
stuff but all of us end up going to
Canada or Mexico and just taking their
drugs and bring them back in our
suitcases because they're they're
drugstores you can go walk in and grab
whatever you want
I've had a few questions people go in
um
why don't they just do Sears after the
movie and I keep trying to say to people
I keep trying about the the plan was
always franchise the point was always TV
series but Jennifer salkey's just kind
of interest that she wants to do a movie
first
so let's see how that develops because
it seems like Jennifer sulk is the only
one that wants a movie first
um that was always okay
it was always the case that she was the
only one who wanted a movie but she was
pushing so hard for it and because she's
like the head she gets her way so
we just have to suck it up basically
well yeah but it seems like everyone
else is gonna have to suck it up but I
know
um that Michael Wright who's the head of
MGM plus was really not happy about this
and he says that look we've all this
work has been done we've always been
gearing up towards a TV series penguin
and Parker have done all this work
gearing up towards a TV series and then
last minute you turn around and go let's
do a movie I was like
it's not you know it's just like why
why we don't why yeah
um
Parker have done
gonna be using the movie they're gonna
have to do something else
yeah we'll work around what they've done
to lead what they've done
do you know like the one thing I'm gonna
I'm gonna do a video on this everything
I've learned about how the movie
industry and stuff works over the last
two years talking to to people since we
started the Sidetrack thing and I I
always assumed there were plans
and people that actually knew what they
were talking about and you know like
things are planned years in advance
because these things cost so much money
to produce you know and uh excuse me and
that they they and they say it seems to
me
instead of there being plans and clever
people it seems like there's a bunch of
headless chickens wandering
what are we gonna do now
it's just like there's no no there seems
to be no coherence to it it's like we've
said it for a few times this is like a
roller coaster it's like it's like
there's all the pig in time it's just
like it's basically they have their own
little meetings and they're like quick
we need an idea what have you got and
there's someone I'll go yeah James Bond
oh yeah we'll do that we'll do that uh
Stargate yeah yeah we'll do that yeah go
ahead yeah
yeah yeah Jennifer soccer let's do a
movie no no we don't like that we're
doing a movie we've just spent two years
doing you know planning something else
and we're doing a movie
um but but yeah so
I it shocks me I'm gonna I say I'm gonna
I'm gonna get into it and do a couple of
videos on it on the side Channel
probably like everything I've learned
about how the movie industry works but
it's it's it's it's it's astonishing
how it doesn't it just doesn't work but
anyway so today's video we were going to
have a think about if if this movie gets
made
what movie do you want to see
um you guys been thinking about it
you've brought a couple of ideas
that hurts so badly
I'll be honest I didn't know the title
of this video until until I joined
over the last two weeks I've repeatedly
said bring movie ideas guys so okay you
just have to think of one I know Harris
is I've got ideas for the movie of it
yeah okay I've been so busy this week
I've not looked at my phone that much to
be iPhone can be completely honest
I've been out of town so I'm gonna use
that excuse as well but I did
I did yesterday my my happy little high
self was was coming up with a
spin-off of era's Bach with Matt already
making fun of me because Aaron's Bach is
the character that should have been used
everywhere and always and we only got
them once so I've I've got a whole live
Junior I love that I love that character
um so the Bounty Hunter so you want to
see the a bounty hunter movie and yeah I
think obviously I haven't finished
Target Atlantis or Stargate Universe I'm
still slowly but surely finishing my way
but if if Stargate Universe is kind of
that type of show people like on a ship
why not use some Bounty Hunter stuff
going on and just make it make it fun
have have a good time with it
Explorer yeah I was [__] is the Boba
Fett of
of Stargate for you and Hunter spot
okay
I'll take it they'll be better than what
we've got
well I mean the thing for the movie I'd
love to see something like that in the
extended I almost said extended Universe
then but I immediately sort of had a DC
sort of pain
not even just this pain another one
um I don't want the next engines but I'd
love to see something like that in when
we start if they do like that Marvel
style lots of little mini series and
things which I'd love something like
that would be amazing to to go off in um
I think oh Christ I really wish I never
after I'd sit down and lie there it's so
painful
um to um you know like wander off and
see his character do something
um not just in one episode but like five
or six episodes that would be that would
be cool I would enjoy it that'd be so
much fun
as well that'd be quite interesting why
he ended up the way he is I mean I think
it does touch on on the episode but like
actually like properly delve into it
well the only things we have are that
that one episode and then they have one
comic book which I ordered the comic
book and it ended up being a Collector's
Edition on accident I only paid 25 for a
collector's edition so I'm a happy
camper
very cool very cool so um we did a poll
on the channel and we basically said um
what do you want from a movie
um we had well over 1500 votes so thank
you very much guys whoever voted I said
do we want an sg1 Style movie would we
want something maybe based on SGA would
we want maybe something around SGU would
you want a hard reboot or you're not
bothered as long as it's not a hard
reboot so 25 of people said I don't care
as long as it's not a hard reboot and
I'm like respect
um about seven percent I think it was
said
um I want a hard reboot and I I
understand the thinking but no thank you
but we'll discuss each option
sg1 was the next biggest like 20
Atlantis came in about 10 but SGU came
in at like a third I think it was like
36 of people said I want an SGU movie
what are your while I cry over here
it's the biggest like crying point for
any Stargate fan that SGU didn't get a
conclusion yes we I spoke about this we
spoke about this so many times the first
season whatever you might you like it
you don't like it whatever the second
season was really good and it was
getting better wait a second wait a
second really good
yes really good it's I really I really
really like Stargate Universe I will die
on the hill this target universe is like
topped here
top drawer
yeah they're they're all they're all
I mean Universe compared to the rest of
stuff I mean compared to other sci-fi
I'm 100 with you it's it's it's better
than most of the rest of the crack we
have to put up with but compared to sg1
no but su1 had a finale sg1 was over
that had a satisfying ending SG Atlantis
also had somewhat of a satisfying ending
it wasn't like fully closed off but it
ended the the threat that was ongoing
in that in that in that season in Target
Universe
it all just like Went to went apart and
yeah
the second season was amazing
it was amazing it wasn't it was better
than the past
it was it was still quite boring
no no it wasn't
so from someone who hasn't seen it at
all and loved Stargate but also loves
General sci-fi
how would each of you compare it to the
first season of the expanse
that's better than the expense
yeah yeah okay the expanse is good
I think I do really like the expanse but
yeah
if you're gonna compare any Stargate
series to the expanse I think you should
compare SGU to it SGU is the most
is the most similar style and I mean
because expanses
excuse me it's a very serious
it takes itself quite seriously
and and so does the expanse it takes
itself seriously it's it's a serious
show
sg1 and SGA don't get me wrong the
serious shows still but they had a bit
of fun there but so unless you use the
one that I would stylistically say is
closest
okay that makes sense but I'm just
trying to see if I can do a
um
a little pole a little pole but I'm
going to wonder if I can do in the
there's a way to do it in chat
um so um
if you're gonna do a
um
I'll see if that works in a minute
because I've never done it before so
we'll see if I can set up a do a pole
while we're live
um
so sorry mind wandering I can't I can't
see how to do it so I'm not going to try
um so if if we have to do an SGU movie
then I quite like the idea of it ending
where it started if that makes sense
so you know it's like oh no starting
where it ended so it'd be like it'd be
like that's typical thing so right so
SGU but some people I've done some of
the comments we've had is SGU killed
Stargate so why would you go back to it
and start it again
I don't I don't think it was the show
that killed Stargate looking at
everything that happened around that
time it wasn't the show that was the
problem sci-fi was probably the biggest
problem by moving the slot
yeah that's why the ratings tanked
initially yeah there was that there was
the vocal minority and it is a minority
who well I'm not going to watch that
because it's stylistically very
different to SGA and SG sg1 but it was
still
well look at all the
people who want SGU
yeah they are there are there are
hundreds of thousands of us like
Millions there are loads of us like we
it was a good show
yeah
boy but anyway yeah
I'm in a bad mood so I'm just going to
destroy both of you right so
um
Mike right
so it it end Stargate ended with SGU
right yes and it ended because of poor
ratings and that's just that's just fact
um when the guy and I think sci-fi I
don't I don't agree with you that they
changed the the slot and that's what
killed it
they were trying to do anything they
could I mean the guy that was the
um Chief exec the second Chief Executive
um sci-fi at the time actually wrote an
open letter that um was
um published on gateworld and he
basically apologized he said you know we
we love this show we really thought it
was going to be more than it was and we
really did everything we could to do and
one of the things was we even tried to
try to change the time start to see if
we could find the audience and nothing
worked
um I would argue the same it was getting
better Stargate Universe was getting
better but I don't think it ever got to
the point of being good
not compared to sg1 and SG Atlantis it
just it wasn't it it was too the ratings
the ratings being so low wasn't the
reason it ended anyway it was it was the
bankruptcy
the bankruptcy again it's one of those
things that they'd already decided after
the two seasons it was everyone was
signed up for two seasons so if they'd
gone to a third season it would have
cost more to make because they'd have to
sign everybody up again the actors Etc
so it costs more to run the Canadian
dollar was really strong against the
American dollar at the time so it was
costing more to run to make the
bankruptcy then I I don't think the
bankruptcy happened then didn't it
happen like three years after that
I'd have to double check my dates I
haven't pretty much around about the
same time it was 2011.
what is that let's have a quick look so
that didn't help but I mean lots of
other shows have survived
uh MGM oh no that's MTM results
bankruptcy so you put in MGM bankruptcy
and lots of things come up
um I just think there was like a load of
Stargate projects got canned at the same
time it was SG SGU obviously was the
main one because that's the one was that
was actually running but you had the
Stargate Atlantis x uh so Extinction
which was the Atlantis movie that was in
pre-production that never got made there
was resurrections was it Resurrection or
resolution something something like that
that was the sg1 movie another extra one
movie in like pre-pre-production kind of
thing that got scanned and then you had
Stargate worlds which was an MMO that
was pretty much finished
pretty much ready to launch and then the
backwards you happen to that they
scrapped the whole lot everything I
think the um the SG-1 movie didn't
happen maybe because Continuum didn't do
great
as well though
um so that that didn't help
I think continuums like the strongest
out of the two I I always like the arc I
like darker truth I thought that was
great but um but continue I was balling
it yeah anything on the Barling and RDA
back in it and everything but let's go
back to the movie then so if we did an
SGU movie
do you want to see would it be as simple
as saying we just go rescue him
is is can we do something simple as that
or does there need to be more to it
there'll be the the the overall I think
the overall idea would be in the end
they end up getting rescued but we we
could see essentially what's happened in
the last 10 years with did Eli manage to
fix the Pod and put himself in stasis or
did he die
is he is he still around that's got to
be one of the biggest questions did he
sit in the chair did he like do that
weird Ascension thing that um
that chair dog I can't remember what
they called that but the weird attention
thing uh or did did he just
die of starvation
um
what happened to the rest of the crew
what happened what happened from the
moment they all went into stasis to the
moment where he was no longer in no
longer on the ship either dead or in
stasis what happened in between that
time and then we can go back to Earth we
can see what's happened on their side
over the last 10 years or so power
source has been found they found a
planet maybe it's in Pegasus
um maybe the Asgard core because we know
that the Asgard have ships that are
capable of traveling between galaxies
within a matter of hours maybe they have
developed a hyperdrive Engine That Could
actually reach destiny
maybe that's a possibility because the
problem with these really has been
traveling at light speed for a million
years
yeah at light speed it's not a couple of
galaxies away is it it's hundreds of
galaxies away
yeah
that's that's fine but if if the Asgard
and travel from Ida to Pegasus from
either galaxy to the Milky Way in a
matter of two hours
just imagine how far they could travel
in two weeks yeah
um which is how long it takes us to get
from Milky Way to Pegasus it takes two
weeks with our standard hyperdrives with
the updated ones how long would it take
because the problem with
um the whole rescue thing was with
Stargate people I've seen people on
Facebook specifically
um posing ideas of how they can rescue
them and they've posed questions like
can we use a black hole to dial to
Destiny
the answer to that is probably yes you
can use the power of a black hole to
create a stable Wormhole that will
actually travel across to Destiny but
the problem is it's a one-way it's a
one-way gate and if you use a black hole
that Gate's never going to close
yeah so they have they have to find a
way for them to get them they have to
find a way for Destiny to either dial
home or then go to Destiny and that's
what that's what the movie is going to
have to be about so we get errors box
son to go safe
you haven't got this far in the in the
argument no I have no ideas
about the best of it yeah I I've always
actually thought though that the um
the whole idea with the Destiny was that
they um have this seed ship and it goes
off into the deep Galaxy and it plants
Stargates and it goes along
um and they were searching for this
mysterious signal that's um in the
background origination of the universe
excuse me
shouldn't drink diet coke live because
then it makes me burp but it helps the
headache a little bit but anyway
um I've so I've always thought there
must have been that oh sorry there's
then crew if you use the beta Cannon the
comic book and this was what Joseph and
those and stuff were thinking about
doing so I think we can say pretty
pretty accurate there's actually crew
aboard
the destiny in stasis
and they woke up they were supposed to
wake up in series three
um and they were engineers sort of thing
there must have been a plan
for
the Ancients didn't eventually go to the
destiny so we know that's that was the
planet that we actually set the if the
first time I think the crew that was on
Destiny wasn't meant to be there though
I think they accidentally I I think I
think in the comic
I'm pretty sure
that it was in the shipyard it was in
the shipyard and it and it launched but
they were still on board when it
launched and they couldn't get off so
they circumstances
yeah I seem to think it was an accident
as well
yeah
yeah but either way so at some point
that my point is to the Ancients also
had a plan to go so there must be ways
to connect us out and we know it's one
at least one Stargate is attached
because it was happened so that there
are ways we can get a Stargate
connection to the destiny getting a ship
to the destiny I think is
um I I just think a million years of
travel and I'm not even sure we're 100
we know where they are
the destiny crew know where they are
because I assume they can look at the
bar charts but I'm not sure yeah they've
got the they've got they've got where
it's traveled from because in the first
episode all the first two or three Eli
brings up this thing and it literally
says this is Earth and then this is us
and it's literally a line drawing of
each Galaxy where it's gone to so they
can they could they could basically so
we've been able to go back and talk to
Statue command so if if one knows any
other one so yeah that's that's right
well if they have star Gates and they
can place them places which just sounds
cool it makes me want to watch it even
more but if they can do that and they
have the accessibility to dial I guess
to certain places they may not be able
to dial all the way back to Earth but if
they could die all the way to Atlantis
even if they couldn't fit a [__] back
couldn't Atlantis just send some puddle
jumpers their way and and put a bunch of
people on them and bring them back power
it requires because the destiny is so
far away in the first part they create a
wormhole and it's literally the the core
of this planet Powers the gate and
activating it destroys the planet
there's this chain reaction and
everything goes it's um
you know Jonas's planet is made up of
the quadria yes essentially those types
of planets and they literally plug into
the planet because it's so reactive it
generates all this massive power but
they can't get the calculations right
um so they literally they get the
connection but the calculations are off
slightly so it literally overloads and
the planet explodes
yeah and that that's happened twice
spoilers Harris spoilers but that
happens
that just sounds awesome
the pros and cons in of doing an SGU
movie right so I've always said that
when you do this movie they've got to do
it the way that's going to attract new
viewers
so you can't just
you know
um have something that's going to pit
appease I'm not even gonna say Gators
because I do think within the the
Stargate Universe fan base they race two
camps when it comes to suu there's sort
of my side of it that's found it a
little boring
um and you know and then there's the
other side of it genuinely people think
it's the best of all the star game
and and I get that because it's so
different so we all have different
opinions don't we really like different
things and when something so I think a
lot of people like sg1 quite like SG
Atlantis because it's similar
you know so is this a similar formula
but SGU is different it was really
different so I can understand there's
this two camps
so if you're going to do an SGU movie
that's just about SGU you're immediately
gonna sort of alienate half of the
skaters
aren't you
I'm not apparently I mean people from
sg1
um
maybe SGA
as you can't remember if anyone from SGA
but but people from sg1 were in Slug It
universe so the characters would be
there at the very least I mean I I
honestly don't see how they'd make an
SG-1 movie we'll go into that afterwards
but I understand see how they'd make
that
Atlantis I can kind of see it but SGU is
the only one that really makes sense but
you can still bring in characters from
those other shows because it's all
connected and you can appease Everyone
by bringing those in
I do I do like the the circular sort of
feel of
starting where we ended
and there's such big questions in SGU
that are again I think in a movie though
might be a bit difficult to sort of
answer because I mean we've got properly
like God questions
like a species not just not just the
background radiation signal that Harris
has no freaking clue still what we're
talking about there's also the planet
builders
yeah you know these were big questions
can you do that in a two-hour movie
maybe you don't have to maybe it could
just be something we never find out
well okay so from from coming from not
having seen all these things if it were
a movie if it were a TV show
whichever it may be
couldn't they save if if just say it's a
movie if if couldn't they just save the
Destiny or the whole crew of Destiny
whatever it may be within the First Act
and make that a really action-packed
First Act and have like start it command
or whoever's leading the mission from
afar kind of cut back between the two so
it gives you what's happening in the
real world time on Earth
but they save it within the First Act
and that may set up maybe the climax for
the film itself because oh now these
people for these aliens followed them
back or this mysterious signal now
latched on to the destiny and now it's
following us back to Earth whatever it
may be would that be kind of doable uh
kind of bridge the gap of okay we got
SGU people we've got SG-1 SGA people
we've got the whole Stargate base but
we're also still moving forward
huh the only problem I can see with that
is doing it in the First Act is it might
feel a little rushed because it's one of
those events that's happened that
I think it's going to take something
massive to bring them back I don't think
it's something that you can just
trivially say oh we brought them back
how did you bring them back like we need
to see that would that be if it would
start a film though say all right we're
we're starting as everyone's already
done the research we kind of get that
that Exposition at the beginning of the
film maybe a voice over like oh this is
what we're doing this is our plan some
kind of way you could do it as like a
command in Stargate and then
I think you could literally do a long
thing of everything that's happened in
the last 12 years Star Wars style I
think it could literally be First Act
we've got
Stargate command now Homeworld command
um in Atlantis whatever whatever it
might be but it's set on Earth and
they're literally formula formula
formulating formulating a plan
and then they they tell the audience
what the planet plan is and the plan is
to save the crew of the destiny who 10
years ago were trapped in a in a distant
galaxy far far away someone who hasn't
watched Target that's still pretty
exciting where it's still pretty
exciting
they can enact the plan that they've got
Shenanigans happen
like people die like aliens attack
there's there's stuff that happens and
in the Final Act there's
reuniting of families uh we can see Eli
with his mum ah it would be
that's what I want
gosh nearly fell asleep you explaining
it oh boy shut up
I don't even laugh too much
Karma
before we go on to talk about like the
other possibilities then what do you
think about the thought that they can
it's such a big universe why don't they
just do a movie that's
none of these things you know I did um I
did a video last week and I said why we
could just do a ronin Dex movie right
you bring back Jason Momoa
um who if you give him enough money
you'd probably do it
um and he seems to be one of those
actors that would if he's I think he's
quite busy the next few years it
wouldn't happen anytime soon but
um and you do a film it's just about him
within the Stargate Universe but really
hasn't got a lot to do with anything
else that follows it it's just like a
two-hour advert for the film for the
series
it's such a big universe couldn't you
you could do a Stargate movie
that that anybody could sit and watch
because it's just like should they maybe
do something that's separate from what's
come before is what I'm trying to say
and that anyone can watch you don't have
to have watched Stargate to understand
it but have enough like things in there
that Gators would go
something you mean like an heiress black
Junior movie
yes exactly like an aerospot [__]
Jack Gordon he's alive
um yeah exactly like that
here's an idea on that vein
the the people of Nova
um is it Nova yeah Nova whatever the
basically our descendants who got what
we got sent back in time and when they
populate the planet
um it could literally be them because
it's an Earth-like planet but it's not
earth
okay
so so you're you're saying it could be
it could be
anyone in the universe doesn't have to
be us here and now
so it could be them which technically is
us but not here and now
they could do it yeah a certain alien
maybe it's an alien race that find their
Stargate
the first five minutes of the film you
have an alien race that's fine there
Stargate they they figure out to dial it
and they come through and it's us and
they arrive in Stargate command that
might be an interesting way it might be
yeah like explaining it all as well what
if we were the antagonists until we
learned to work together or something
like that like like the humans in the
Jafar and everybody were the antagonists
at the beginning
hmm might be interesting
so we're the Bad Guys
until we're not of course but I mean it
just depends who's in power doesn't it
yeah yeah
I I do like the idea of of however they
do this as well that we become sort of
the bad guys
um
audience
was bought born out of
um freeing themselves From Slavery and
taking what what was
uh used to oppress them and then they
become
bad guys
yeah a lust for knowledge becomes Your
Lust for power easily
well we're the baddest people in the
Galaxy at the moment when we our
starships are going to be better than
anyone's because we have got the ancient
I'm sorry the um the Asgard database
still and well even without increasing
our knowledge to say even if we haven't
really learned anything in 10 years
we've still got the best ships in the
fleet in in the universe that we know of
we're better than anything Lucian lines
have got
um there's only really The Ore either
could touch us
the only thing that would would be would
make it hard for us would be people
coming in greater numbers and that's
what I think they've they've they've
done that with a lot of the the enemies
in the past out with The Wraith
yeah we can defeat the hardship dead
easy but they come with like 15 Hive
ships and we're like
[__] I could not we could not defeat
them and we have to run that's even if
we're like the most powerful beings
essentially technologically in the
Galaxy it's just going to be who's got
the bigger Army
like crazy you know we'd have to be
building a fleet we can't just have five
or six ships
not to get too Star Wars with it but we
already have all the Asgardian
technology and their clones who who
what's keeping anybody from literally
making a clone army anywhere just
resources or or what because that'd be a
I don't I don't think they would they
would touch the clothing technology
simply because of what happened to the
Asgard
what if it was a means to an end like
the cold war just uh to take out some
things not necessarily live long
longevity wise
always interesting but then there's then
there's the the debate ethically of
is is this exactly the route that the
Asgard went down initially they were
only going to make small changes here
and there and then they did it more and
they did it more and they did it more
and then all of a sudden they've got
this degradation they can't they can't
repair and now that they're gonna die
and numbers aren't really our problem
are they because we've got billions of
people all over the Galaxy we can we can
we don't really need more
um I I think that we're gonna have
issues with like refugees and things and
we're gonna have lots of issues like
that but we discussed this this one
we've talked about
does it make sense that that it would
still be a secret on Earth and like why
would we give we give our technology and
an equity generators to people on
planets mainly miles away but we still
use coal power stations it doesn't make
sense
everybody right so you said like you
didn't really know how an sg1 series
would go for me I think that's that's
the easiest one you've got you'd there'd
still be an sg1 team an sg2 team an SG3
team so you still got Stargate command
um you bring back a couple of the actors
like you know
um you bring back General Sam you bring
back Daniel Jackson according to sources
they've already been approached
um and I've already pretty much agreed
that whatever project moves forwards
they're going to be in it and that is an
amazing cook
um and I like the blood
oh man it's even better a little Zoom
work down there oh yeah
um so I mean for me it's a
starting point it seems to be the
easiest because you don't really need to
explain much
um how the story then what story then
develops is
like you can go you can go anywhere with
it
um but from a from a if they're being
lazy
it seems to be the easiest way to do it
and the easy way I can see I can see it
being one of the easiest options for
sure but
the problem I see
because sg1 ran for so long they did so
much they defeated so many like
evils they defeat the goal defeat the
replicators and then they've defeated
ascended beings where'd you go from
there
with Atlantis and stuff it was in a
different galaxy so you can have
different threats and stuff with the
universe different parts different parts
of the universe so you can have
different threats there but in our own
Galaxy
what's what's going to be a bigger
threat than the ascended beings from
erotic Galaxy
failings
evil Ewoks
to be honest maybe I mean the feelings
isn't the villain at some point in the
first two or three seasons of whatever
they bring back I I don't know what to
say
I just think I think if you don't you've
got the biggest question from sg1 that's
never been answered been hinted at a few
times we've seen a few aliens we think
oh we think they're the furlings we're
not sure and the planet Builders might
be the furlings we're not sure
um if you don't bring them back I don't
know what what is going on and obviously
they're not evil E rocks actually need
to remind people that the Jack O'Neill
that was his imagination when we see the
furlings they're not going to be evil
Ewoks
um it just amazes me how many times we
get comments I got that'll just look
stupid don't you can't do that now we
don't know what the feelings look like
come there
um we didn't do it they did it in the
episode 200 it was a Parody episode yeah
exactly so um
but but like I say you've got the
biggest question from from Target sg1
I I Gators would go I think most Gators
go freaking crazy oh my gosh the
failings brilliant but you could bring
those into any it doesn't have to be a
directly from sg1 it could be they could
go into Atlantis they could go into
Universe I mean even if they did
something completely different Stargate
Galaxy I don't know
top of my head to some random random
show you could bring in ever like one
one villain from every single series can
still be in this new one and that's the
beauty of it
could be anything
if we're talking furlings why not talk
Knox I mean the knocks are obviously
super friendly and everything but
they're also much more
focused on making sure things are are
good in nature on different planets and
it's they're kind of living with the
planets if we're going around exploding
planets just to open up freaking
Stargates places why wouldn't they be
pissed off at us hey this young race is
coming around and yeah the species might
be smart they might be intelligent and
capable of figuring all these things out
but you're still a young species young
race that doesn't know what they're
doing and that much I guess that that
much in that little of time might be
dangerous to them and the furlings we we
could see them kind of take over they
did distance themselves from the Towery
because of essentially how how we are as
a species and then they've got that line
that that Blake says was it sometimes do
not do his days old yeah I thought that
would be a really easy way again of
something if we have a villain I I like
the idea of the Towery being the villain
yeah it's not like not not the Goa World
sort of villain but we're going out
there we're
we're building cities we're building
things like like you said we blow up the
odd star yeah and the knocks who are
supposedly
um
hippies they're hippies you'd get on
with them great Harris
um so um because you know that anyway
um so I mean b The Knocks turn up and
just go no
you you guys need to we're going to put
you in your place you're too young and
you're effing everything up that you go
around and maybe they come in and they
put us they put us down
I mean they if we fought ascended beings
we fought all these different things
they're gonna know we won't be easy to
defeat which means they're going to come
in there with the plan
which would be interesting yeah without
the thing we don't know our technical
technologically advanced they are you
know because because we we only got
Snippets we saw floating cities we saw
things like this so they could literally
just come in and click their fingers and
just say
they have ships but bring a floating
city to another planet and then make it
an uninvisible and and like show that
it's in on the planet just out of
nowhere kind of deal and then from there
if you have a floating city why not have
six or seven different Destiny type
Vehicles six or seven Prometheus type
Vehicles whatever it may be come down
there and just start attacking people
and then you have I mean you literally
have an invisible way of bringing in an
entire planetary like force to take
something over and they could do that in
in a couple Jaffa worlds they could do
it at a couple Towery worlds they could
do it where we're building up somewhere
and we wouldn't have anything to do
against it we could start the series
that they they wouldn't be
attacking anyone
if they were to be an antagonist they
would they would be very clever
and they would probably take people
um they would probably stop people from
doing certain things
I don't know to what extent they could
do but they're very peaceful race I mean
they wouldn't even let us let um SG-1
kill up office
you know yeah like even though he'd
potentially killed them and they brought
him back to life like he didn't they
just wouldn't let him do it and they all
look like image
um if if you're not if you're not yeah
they do an American woman the hell I'm
talking about they'll do like Google
um so um
I like the idea of this from like a it's
it's like a philosophical idea and they
say but I actually think it's a movie I
don't think there's a lot of like to
make it very exciting because it would
be kind of like
you know there'd be a good moral to the
story you know that we have become too
powerful too quickly and you know we've
become greedy or whatever
um I think over a series I'd like to see
bits off that because we we'd stumble
wouldn't we we're new as a galaxy Power
I think we'd stumble
um
and we're quite a greedy crap race if
you really break it now we're not very
good
um I love that bit when it says um like
uh O'Neill's talking to Hammond and
Hammond's there saying we're not going
to interfere in this this planet's
um
um political whatever and he goes since
when when do we not do that and and it's
true you know like I saw that little
thing that it's it was always sg1 was
always sort of like the ideal star
tricky you know one thing you know they
tried they were trying to get weapons
and they didn't like the nid because
they were trying they were stealing
things you know so they tried to be
idealistic but every so often you just
see little images of like no we're not
really we're quite greedy and we're
quite and we're political and I love the
political episodes when we're a very
fractured society as well
as a society as a race as a species
we're very fractured because we've got
what we've got but we've got self
borders that we created so we've got
like America we've got England we've got
Africa and stuff and then we impose like
laws and sanctions on people on the
other side of a border
just because they live on that side of
the Border
and there's a lot of infighting between
like one on one side of the defense to
the other side of the fence just because
the grass is greener on this side oh the
Cross isn't that green on that side and
it's it's crazy but
with
if they were to do it with a movie I
think having that be
part of it there's a lot of infighting
and because we're not a unified race
we're not
we don't have like one Central like
government kind of thing
there's a lot of like power vacuums
um and whoever owns the Stargate has the
power so
there's a lot of friction to be had from
that oh people
um we just had a a little quick question
did the Ancients forget about this the
um
sorry they didn't forget about Destiny
no they kind of well they because they
launched it a million years before to
answer this question and then they
ascended basically so I think once the
Ancients ascended
they became energy beings they'd have
just
found all the answers to what just
Destiny became redundant basically so
they just left it
um forget about it it just became it
just didn't become important anymore
once they ascended instead
um so but obviously by the point of uh
that launching I think some of the
Ancients had already started ascending
aren't they I think I have read the
timeline a few times
um but these were the atlanteans and
when it was about ascended beans there's
two or three different types isn't there
so it was slightly before Atlantis went
to Pegasus
yeah their first slot started to ascend
there's more than there was more than
one Ascension buffer so you've got
because then you've got they've got the
atlanteans with a bunch of ascended and
you've got the Ancients I think is a
general term but then occasionally
they'll they talked about um them or the
others which was a bunch of ascended
beans as well that they were the ones
that were very strict on not interfering
So within the ancient culture I'll I'll
do a video on the Ancients at some point
because
as far as I know there was there was a
the settlement on Earth
some of them some of them would have
ascended
they then there was obviously had
Atlantis already so they went to Pegasus
um and then they had the war with The
Wraith and then after that the rest of
them ascended that's as far that's how I
understand it
um and then after the aura and then
there was a there's a bunch of
ascensions after the when the Aur I used
the um
uh the plague as well and there's the
last lot of ascensions were about 10 000
years going into the final ones I think
and then 50 000 years ago is when but
anyway goes on and on I'll do a video at
some point because it is quite
complicated
um
so
we don't we we think an SGU movie could
work but we're not sure whether it would
happen broad enough appeal is that fair
yeah I don't know because the the the
the idea I've got no the idea
would make it work for anyone who hasn't
seen Stargate before you start with
Earth you start with them saying they're
gonna go and they're gonna go and rescue
these people that have got been on this
ship for the last 10 years you don't
have to have watched Target to
understand that all you know is cool
they've been on that ship for a long
time let's go rescue them and then you
go along for the ride
I think that would appeal to a large a
large range of people and and finale is
them getting home you have problems you
do whatever the finale they come home
does that lead into a new series
does that need into a franchise or is it
just a nice way to say goodbye to the
old franchise move forward
something can happen at the end of it
that would lead into this into the
series maybe as Harry said something
came back with them
or the Destiny's woken something up that
is a new threat or whatever and then
it's going okay well there's Earth
um I was thinking it's a bit like when
the Enterprise first just got the ball
and then they knew and Q was like they
know where you are now so the threat
wasn't immediate but the Borg knew where
the Federation was so it sort of they
came they could do something like that
the Destiny's woken something up they've
survived they come back and then they're
like yeah but they know we're here now
and they didn't know before it's kind of
like I suppose what they did with the
aura as well that's a similar sort of
storyline they were like oh we thought
you were all dead
um
I knew we were dead from that plague
they didn't know that a dakara weapon no
we've been protecting us all that time
the Ancients have been shielding us so
um
so sg1 is the easiest way of doing it SG
Atlantis I think I don't think we need
an SG Atlantis a movie unless we can get
um
um uh Jason Momo to come back but I do
think
we're going to see the Atlantis because
I would have thought that would make
total sense if we've got an SG command
on Earth I think you mentioned earlier
Matt that it would be Atlantis if
Atlantis is still on Earth
um so SG command would be Atlantis so I
think we'll see if she I think we could
see SGA I just don't think I don't think
all it is is a ship it's another ship to
put into our Arsenal yeah a big one yeah
it's a massive one but they could
literally be
in any show any movie it can it can show
up
that's true what what where what what
does like the Pegasus Galaxy like how
does it fit into all this I guess
because obviously I don't know exactly
where things in so it's but
how does that fit into any of this
that's my there is a lot of unanswered
questions in in Pegasus
the the overall threat of The Wraith
isn't defeated it's just the immediate
threat to Earth
gets defeated
um but the overall threat in Pegasus
isn't so there is still the unanswered
question of how are they going to
eradicate that threat how are they going
to finish what the Ancients started like
50 000 years ago so yeah
all basically Atlantis entry there's a
threat against Earth because the they
they get a bunch of zpms and they send
this like super Hive ship and that's all
that really ends with Atlantis is that
the super Hive ships defeated so Earth
is saved
but there's still an entire galaxy full
of people being hunted by the race
interesting so so if could could that be
a kind of a way to like bridge the gap
like maybe if you get some villains or
or get or or I don't know if we are the
villains in in whatever series or movie
it may be could we find a way to kind of
push people towards or whatever enemies
we may have towards the Pegasus Galaxy
and kind of Let The Wraith start to help
us in a way even without them know what
to kind of feed them without like really
dinner time yeah essentially you know
I think that if if they brought in any
anything from Atlantis
they'd have a race as allies we've
already had our wreath as allies like
you've got Todd uh even though I think
you know the overall like
I swear he backstabbed us but I can't I
can't really remember
I swear he does
right at the end doesn't he
can't remember or is that not Todd
Todd I think is in season Michael
Michael
I think he ended up I can't remember the
last time we saw him he backs down then
gets back stabbed and then backstabs The
Wraith and helps us yeah yeah and that's
the same with toddrin isn't it that Todd
keeps
it's a bit like ball
you know they they follow the same form
formulas in between SGA and sg1 so right
so we've said basically SGU will be
boring we've agreed that sg1 is
we have not agreed that
a second SGU will be born and democracy
I can't get him back in sorry so SGU
would be boring sg1 would be
um uh easy but maybe is it too easy I
think somebody just said there that
actually sg1 is it run its course
um I would say that it's formulaically
the easiest way to do a new franchise
because you can
you know it's it's a it's like having a
Star Trek series aboard the Enterprise
it just makes sense and it's what people
want to see but SG Atlantis we think
will appear and be Central to whatever
comes but maybe won't be like the you
know like the reason for things even
though I've always said we'll have
Engineers all over SGA all over the
Atlantis they can very easily find
something that causes a massive problem
that this the initial storylines around
and then just go into a room and go oh
crap I can just let something yeah
um
um and
you know I I I
think for me I want to see a hybrid you
know I want to see them cherry pick the
best bits out of all three
that we will get to see actors from all
three maybe and we get to see something
exciting and maybe with it I think the
the idea I had was that we'd have an sg1
franchise with maybe new
younger actors because obviously if
they're the front line they're going to
be maybe 20s 30s with all of these
cherry-picked
you know the the great actors that we
love in and around it
and and that would be a great way of
setting up the franchise and then you
maybe you know you each series would
like switch
um where it's focusing
so I think she'd focus on
the tower area but you could focus on
maybe an ancient storyline you could
focus on so you could focus on lots of
things you could go to the Jaffa Nation
or you could focus on that a little bit
um
that's the way I'd like to see it but
before we end and I go and lie down and
put my head in a pillow and just go and
for a bit
hard reboot
it's always a risk
we don't in our hearts we don't want to
see it
but
would it be a better way
of restarting the franchise
if you think about how powerful Tyree
were
at last everything what a clean paper
yes on paper in theory it's it's very
easy to do a hard reboot and just
eradicate all the progress we've made
but I think it's just as easy to bring
in some something in the story to get
rid of that power
yeah
like I mean I'm still finishing it why
would I finish it if we do a hard reboot
it would feel like I've
I mean I still could but like wow why
would I watch the reboot then just for
the sake of it well that wouldn't I
don't think there's a legitimate reason
for it except dollars and I'm all four
dollars I'm a Texas boy at Exxon mobil's
headquarter in the city I'm from like I
like money all day every day but you got
to have reason for your art and if that
only reason is is oh yeah this would be
easier
off with that you know like give me
something real and and heartfelt that's
one of the reasons why it is sad that
Amazon doesn't want to use Brad or
malozi or any of these people is like
not only are they had the creative minds
behind this but they're the hearts and
souls behind it and and that that can be
replaced if you have the right people
and the right Shepherds and things like
that but a hard reboot makes absolutely
no sense and it would feel like I mean
for someone who's been watching this for
the past year and a half to two years
really just trying to get further and
further into it and enjoying every
little second of it hmm y'all that have
watched it and and adored it for the
last 15 20 years I don't know how that
make y'all feel I'd just feel completely
betrayed a soft reboot's fine for me but
a hard reboot I I'm gone there's no
reason for me to watch it it's gonna
have to be it's too much time for it not
to be some version of a soft read but
it's going to be Star Trek yeah Stargate
to the Next Generation in some way that
we might get a few actors come back like
we've said
um but
I'd hope if that they they would look at
other shows that got rebooted and failed
like the what the one I can think of
straight away because it it's
similar story to Stargate where it
basically Ended as it was getting good
it was The 4400 so that ended in 2000
and
2008 something like that I think it's
about 2008. yeah well I really liked it
so it ended right right pathway through
the
full season
fifth yeah yeah I did watch the first
season to be fired I did quite like it
but then I think I he's one of those
shows getting really good yeah it was on
sky and I didn't have sky for a bit so I
stopped watching it and then I never got
back into it sort of thing but it was
getting really good they canceled it and
then literally like two years ago they
bought it back they rebooted it and it
no one watched it because it was not
good
and it didn't get past the first season
so maybe hopefully they look they look
at like stuff like that like oh
this is an example of a show that didn't
get its ending and they tried to reboot
it hard reboot it
it failed maybe we should just continue
it just a continuation bring back the
people who were in it before
if they've got like any sense like
that's what they'll do but you know as
you said before they're just headless
chickens so who knows yeah the the thing
is though I think there's no need for a
hard reboot now because of streaming
services
yeah 10 years ago
they'd have done it because
um they only had repeats and people
didn't watch the repeats as much as they
do nowadays nowadays
they would have done an Amazing
Spider-Man just like they did in
Spider-Man and hard rebooted one of the
most popular characters where this is
like one of the most popular franchises
that as we say sleeping giant people
adore it you can't do something like
that with something people love and have
spent Toby had three movies how are you
supposed to like Andrew Garfield and if
it declines in quality at all why would
you stay that's the same way for like a
hard reboot now just ah it's not it's
not a popular idea anymore but because
of streaming services though that whole
thing of well people won't know what
we're on about
if we have all these Easter eggs and
things that's been proven by season
three of Picard that they're talking
about stuff that we did they did a TV
series 30 years ago and there's lots of
these little Easter eggs going back to
three decades ago and people remember
because they've continued to watch it
and they've watched on streaming so the
whole argument of
that it's just that people won't
remember isn't true anymore so a hard
reboot of a franchise's biggest Stargate
is this ridiculous idea but everything
I've heard is not going to happen
everything I've heard is that and even I
mean even um Roland Emerick talked about
this and they said look he wanted to do
his movie and MGM and Amazon even at
that point were not keen and he said
it's because the TV audience is all that
mad they just cared about the TV
audience
um it was because we had 16
17 seasons of this show that we love and
yeah we don't want to we don't want to
pretend but I think they can they can
ignore bits they can they don't have to
maybe
um what I heard was when penguin and
Parker first got involved was then they
were doing the development work it was
with Amazon said you can you can ignore
some bits
if it makes the show make sense
and but there's certain things you can't
and we want this Bible that they that
penguin and Parker Mark figures put
together for them we want this Bible of
what it looks like and and that that God
that was nearly a year ago now
um I think it was like 10 months ago um
so there's this Bible that exists that
Amazon commissioned Mark Fergus to do
before all the pitch meetings thing
started to say this is what you can and
this is what you can't do
and I I like the idea because at least
it comes from a point of saying okay
look we there is a problem in that the
tower you're incredibly powerful there
is a problem that like okay this has
been defeating this has been defeated
this has happened so incredibly powerful
well yeah so where are we allowed to
a little bit to make a show now that
makes sense
it's just I've said it before like the
Towery we're idiots we'll just lose it
like it'll just get blown up or
something it got blown up nearly it
literally got blown up within the first
five minutes of having it so it will it
will happen again Harris you okay sir
oh
Harris go bye bye Harris is rebooting
he's having a hard reboot does he need
to come out and come back in So yeah so
that's that I think that's yeah he's
he's off he's we've lost him but he'll
come back in a second so I think
the nice thing about
um
Stargate is though it's a bit like Star
Trek is that they do have this massive
Universe to go through
I just worry though that they will be
obsessed about bringing things back
right the Star Trek risk Star Trek
always brings back it always has to be
based on the Enterprise
it always has to they have to reboot it
though we have to have a new Captain
Kirk and we have to have a new Pike they
always have to
re-recycle all these old characters
because they think we'll freak out or
not watch it if it's based on a new ship
and a new thing but then to prefer they
did discovery which was a new ship and a
new thing and no one watched it but
anyway we'll ignore that
um I just don't need them to do that I
think there's enough
characters and enough thing there to and
and one of the things I don't want them
to do is I don't want Colonel O'Neill or
generally need to be played by a
different character actor if RDA comes
back great if he doesn't fine
new a new place coming new characters
new activists do not fall into that
mistake that Star Trek have done we're
our third or fourth Kirk we don't need
that I I I I'd hope that wouldn't be a
risk
um just from what we've seen in Stargate
before Don S Davis died
um and they didn't replace him yeah they
didn't
they didn't reflect hire an act to be
General Hammond they they just hired
Beau Bridges who has Landry if they do
other things like that so Jack O'Neill
Sam whatever they're gonna they're gonna
retire at some point Jack probably
already has retired to be fair but Sam
and Daniel and all that they're gonna
they're gonna get old they're gonna
start families and all that kind of
stuff
bring in new characters to uh to replace
them but not new actors to play them
yeah yeah exactly and like I say we just
we just we we it's a big enough Galaxy
that we can support new actors and new
characters you know and um and that's a
nice thing to start getting some massive
Universe
it was always good at that anyway I mean
with sg1 we we were
we all loved SG-1 the team like we
couldn't imagine a show without sg1 and
an Atlantis came along and we had John
Shepard and Taylor and Ronan and and
Rodney
and yeah we'd already met Rodney in sg1
but we fell in love with them as well
and and
I know you didn't but personally I fell
in love with the characters in Stargate
Universe as well so it's happened before
like they bring in new characters and
new stories and it works
Universe I didn't I didn't fall in love
with the characters I think the writing
was it was it was probably the the most
beautifully made of all the three series
production value was through the roof it
was so good it was beautiful I didn't I
didn't like the characters
so SG so with Stargate you that started
SG-1 Stargate Atlantis I like the
characters I feel like they're they're
good people
and I I I genuinely liked them
but I don't like the people in Stargate
Universe I find them interesting to
watch because they're just horrible
people a lot of them are just horrible
people but they're put in this
impossible situation and it's how they
react that's what I enjoy watching
hmm
yeah
so the same way same reason I like that
Breaking Bad it's like a good guy
turning bad somewhere like Dexter he's a
guy who just kills
bad guys like they're they're they're
horrible people they're horrible
characters but they're just so fun to
watch Yeah you mentioned deck structures
another another good example of why a
continuation can work Dexter is off our
screens for 10 or 15 years or something
and they did that Series last year and
it was amazing it was the biggest show
on Showtime actually
um they're now talking about doing two
spin-off shows so I mean it kind of I
was a little annoyed about that that
show though
everything up until the last episode
because they killed Dexter they actually
killed Dexter yeah
put a bit of a dampener on season two
but
um but I mean he faked his death in in
the ape season
um he was supposed to be dead and then
he came back for New Blood so yeah but
lots of um things have
yeah it just proves though that it can
work a continuation can work anyway so I
don't know if the Harris is coming back
but I wanted to have a golden about Star
Wars
before he uh if we disappeared but I
don't think he's going to come back
um but anyway so we've got lots of ideas
for how the movie can work we've had
this update now that
um there might be a mutiny going on at
MGM
over the movie
um that literally I think Jennifer
salkin must be sat in office just going
to bang another dog
I'm moving won't work you stupid cow
um oh I just got a message of Harris my
wife a just went kaput
so he he go bye-bye
um so I don't think he's coming back
but
um it's it's really easy for them to do
a movie there's lots of ways they could
do it I just want them to do a movie
that is basically a two-hour advert for
the amazing television that's going to
follow it my only real disappointment
about a movie first is that it'll take
longer that's my only disappointment if
they announced if they just decided
let's go TV series and they they could
put it could be on our screens for six
months
you know by the end of the year it could
be on our screens it wouldn't be
nowadays because when they do this when
they do streaming service movement those
take longer nowadays but um
spring next year is doable 12 months
doable I think it'd be quicker than that
actually because they've done loads of
development work but if they announce
this it could be on our screens really
quickly
but um and it's because it's character
driven it's not a Sci-Fi driven as
things like Warhammer all these other
series that have come in God of War
um what's the other one
um
uh there's another one they've just
finished filming and it's still not
going to be on our screens for like nine
months or something
um
sorry I sent myself an email about it so
I need to I need to remember to talk
about it
where is it anyway it doesn't matter
um but you know these these things
they're they're big special effects it
doesn't Stargate doesn't have to be as
it's more character driven so it could
be an uh screens a lot quicker if we
wanted it to be but
let's see what happens so um I will get
you a few more details guys about these
Shenanigans and discussions going on at
MGM as soon as I know I'm hoping to know
a little bit more tomorrow
um we've got a few ideas for things
coming up as well
um and yeah we'll we'll crack on with
that immediately thanks very much Matty
for joining us again even though you've
been wrong the entire video I mean
literally everything that's come out of
your mouth has been wrong which is
astonishing mate that's um absolutely
not absolutely not everything I've said
has been
top tier knowledge and top tier opinions
very good it's just your opinion that's
um that's that's that's wrong
um but I mean but you're incredible get
into the comments am I wrong or is Jay
wrong
Clash your votes now on SGU I think
that's going to be Marmite that's going
to be honestly
Stargate universities is is funny do a
poll do a poll after this video
I guarantee you you will get slightly
more SGU votes so so what okay I'm gonna
put the poll on live now while we're on
just say do you do you like SGU
do you like SGU
or opinions on SGU love it hate it like
just just that's just just that oh Sarah
says I'm wrong
um but but he says I'm right no he says
something wrong I am so right so okay
we're going to create a poll right now
and because we are we're not a democracy
I'm in charge but we we're democracy
and we're not I'm not in charge
um
what am I doing with democracy democracy
with democracy yeah unless you're told
to shut up in which case you know what
to do so I told you to shut up today you
haven't said it to me yet
yeah I was I felt sorry for you mate
that you were just so be talking such
rubbished my head oh if you're going to
get away with it you'll get away with it
today because mayor's apparently right
so Stargate Universe
Target Universe love it or hate it is
that a simple
so that's not feathers because I don't
hate it
I just think it's the weakest okay of
the three like it okay like it don't
like it
best well is it
I'll tell you what should we do what is
your favorite Stargate Stargate sg1
Stargate SG Atlantis Target SGU I bet
you that's just unless you want to win
unless you want to win because it's the
best
but I think Atlanta still come third
yeah
okay we'll do that all right
which is the what's the best Target
what is the best Stargate series
or best or favorite or guys tell me in
the thing what is the best stuff best or
favorite
I'll put Stargate origins in there I
want to see how many people vote for
that okay you know what I've never
watched Origins hopefully we're gonna
get
um I could say this actually because I
don't think it's your mind I'm hopefully
going to get Jenny stiven to come on as
a guest in the next couple of weeks
um and what I want to do is get on
against and talk about Origins if she
had a lot of
um she she was there working on it she
was one of the team that worked on it I
have never seen it
I don't it's good it's it's it's it so
come back in not 2018 didn't it gets
something crazy like that we hadn't had
Stargate for so long when it come out I
was dead excited I watched it I watched
a whole lot in that one sitting because
it's like 10
I think it was ahead of its time wasn't
it because it was it was good but it it
wasn't
I don't think you could consider it
Canon
no um well it was supposed to be like a
prequel prequel prequel SG Origins uh
I'm throwing origins in you got it oh
what was the name of the cartoon
Infinity
thank you
I Gotta Throw That in as well
I did watch it and it was it was right
that is live guys that poll is live
please make your votes what was the best
I'm going with best not favorite
all right so what was the best
of the show and that is that is slightly
different
because
um I mean my favorite
um I don't know which I think of an
example now
my favorite Star Trek movie is not the
best Star Trek movie my my favorite Star
Trek movies country it's not the best of
the movies
um but it's my favorite for different
reasons and so actually I want to know
what's the best of the Stargate series
and then
um when I think sg1 in that case it's
always going to be su1
yeah because every day it's the daddy
come on
um and and then we'll I'll follow up
with the Stargate Universe I'll think
how to word it uh when I am gonna
mind splitting headache so um the
starboard universe is still still like
top tier
compared to other sci-fi not compared to
Saga sg1 or SG Atlantis
it's
third draw
compared to all other sci-fi it's still
top draw
it's still better than most the crap out
there I agree with you in half that half
of that
all right I think Harris might be coming
back so I do want to have a go with him
about did you watch the Mandalorian
episode this week
the like half an hour episode yeah the
um with the flying Tyrannosaurus Rex the
foundling
and the found link yeah it's called
what's your thoughts
on that episode
just generally did you enjoy it
was all right
does it really add much to the story
add anything to the story
um it means no bloody sense
right so you've got but the episode
before that didn't add anything to the
story either
yeah I'm I'm detecting a pattern to
honest with this series the episode
before that was literally about this one
guy
who ends up getting betrayed for some
unknown reason and then all of a sudden
we're back to Mandalorian
here he is right so let's well let me
tell you why this was the perfect
culmination of 15 years worth of
Storytelling right here because there
are visuals there's dark Sabers there's
mandalorians there's there's so many
things wrapped up in this beautiful
perfect half hour
it was mentioned it was in the second
episode but okay so so the the
prevalence with that comes from the fact
that we learned that has Vizsla the Big
John Favreau Mandalorian the big dude
that gets shot by the bird and then kind
of tossed out later yeah his son is the
guy that's been taken
usually that doesn't really matter
because mandalorians yeah their
foundlings are almost just as important
as their children
and the Vizslas are the clan that United
Mandalore long long long ago tar vizla
was the first person to wield that dark
saber and ride the mythosaur and unite
all of the bickering clans of
mandalorians right it's okay
it's gonna be great so so that that's
different too just because I'll give you
the briefest of synopsises because no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no Chateau Paris no right the last
episode of Mandalorian
Big Bird comes in
grabs child with with massive claws does
not kill that child no sense that makes
no [__] sense that he does eat it he
does eat it he does that I think
regurgitates it it regurgitates it still
alive in that's that that bird's stomach
how long did Boba Fett sit in the sarlac
stomach with this Mandalorian bescar
yeah which also don't don't don't use
that as an excuse of why it made sense
because that didn't make bloody sense in
there that's the best part I know he's
wearing armor so all right we'll see you
again so he swallows him flies the Big
Bird
flew off right they've tried to follow
him couldn't catch him and then Katie
Sackhoff chased him said I found the
nest has time to come back
land have a chat with them they decide
what to do they then fly back to the
nest
climb a big bloody Mountain
just in time for the Big Bird to arrive
what was the big bird doing they climbed
the mountain and camp overnight and then
do the end
Big Bird was just like flying around in
circles going well I've got to wait for
all these mates to turn up and make no
bloody sense
I know this is science fantasy and I
always wonder that you know they don't
call Star Wars sounds fantasy because
they know it doesn't make any bloody
sense we can't call it sci-fi because
we'll have to make it make sense
so we'll have to call it fantasy because
we're in fantasy we'll do everyone and
then big bird can fly around for [__]
for two days waiting for the
mandalorians to turn up it makes no
bloody sense and the episode
boring as crap
it's just like
the episode before it Paris the episode
before it can you get the episode can
you explain what relevance that has to
anything
it has relevance to everything
some random dude who looks like he's a
[__] person
the guy that we followed in season one
and season two the guy that probably
yeah he's very important we started the
series with him
I I I don't think
but I I appreciate that building to
something but the last episode was
thinking that I've got a controversial
thing to say Harris and and I want you
to listen to me yeah Star Wars is crap
all of it
it's boring
other than that they made really cool
toys out of it right other than how do
you make really cool toys besides really
cool characters some great music
brilliant music love the music I love a
lightsaber give me a lightsaber I'm
happy boy
but the stories are dull
they never really and they're simple
it's good versus evil there's no Nuance
to it there but there is Nuance there's
Nuance in it and that that's the best
part about it they can be these simple
stories with it so let me counter
because one more point
do you know how they call it a Space
Opera
have you ever watched an opera
yeah
born as crap
so that's why it's called the Space
Opera because they know it's boring
so give before I even attempt to counter
give me three reasons how Star Trek is
more entertaining than Star Wars because
that is
boring 100 you did just say Star Trek is
better than Star Wars you know that
right no I said tell me how I didn't say
it tell me tell me three reasons how I
have to give you three reasons why Star
Trek's about the Star Wars more
entertaining more entertaining
um best stores
more interesting stories because they're
actually like used to talk about simple
stories their entire like that's their
goal is to go over here and now we're
gonna show how Humanity's good over here
there there's no Nuance in these stories
from villain and then they all some
mystery or something and they solve the
mystery you know it's just like there's
loads of mysteries they have much better
characters I've got Scooby-Doo for that
have you looked at some of the writing
of Star Wars
yes it is fine everything that's come
since
Star Wars has spawned everything that
has come since because of it I I know I
the only thing I'm grateful for Star
Wars for is that because it was
successful a new hope we got a Star Trek
movie
so that that was good like chilling in
the basement said down here original
Star Wars will never be equaled it will
it just won't oh no no because actually
no this is really controversial
annoyed me I was thinking I enjoyed the
original trilogy though didn't I so I
went back and watched them
the first the New Hope is written so
badly
the you know how like George Lucas was
convinced it was going to flop so he
didn't um go to the premiere he booked
it off to Barbados or something with um
Steven Spielberg and they thought up
Indiana Jones while they're on holiday
instead of going to the premiere and I
think it's because it's written really
badly the the
um
them talking to each other I can't think
of the proper word is awful in places
dialogue the dialogue it's really bad in
places it's really I mean it's really
like cheesy and and awkward
um and the dialogue has never been
perfect
no no but it's it's really bad in the
first one I think it got better in the
second two but um
honestly I just
I don't hate Star Wars I don't mine is
just imagination I love the first the
first three movies the good films
um I just I think a lot of the
television and I love those two scenes
it's a Mandalorian I love bits of Boba
Fett
um but my God it's boring you really I
don't get excited about the new star
Star Wars do you actually get excited on
Wednesday when the new Mandalorian
episodes coming out a thousand percent
but part of that is because I grew up
watching the Clone Wars y'all literally
don't have
12 to 15 years of Storytelling that and
and not only is it good storytelling
that is is George Lucas
helmed and Dave filoni helmed which is
George Lucas's like protege
it it it uh
it it's it's a type of Storytelling Dave
filoni and George Lucas tell a story in
in ways like they're it's it's
interesting to go back and watch it now
because as a kid I loved every little
bit of it but now the first two seasons
of Clone Wars I'm like all right this is
slow this is this isn't exactly what I
want it to be but you literally just
just patience is paid off in Star Wars
which is great because there's your
nuances right there is it takes a little
bit of time to get somewhere and once
you get somewhere you feel that much
more fulfilled because of what what may
feel feel I guess filler-ish isn't
fillerish by definition ever in Star
Wars it progresses a story and it
continues to tell something which I like
and here's my counter for a Little Star
Trek right there is I I don't dislike
Star Trek either
I find it just so so boring because I
could literally watch any it's a
procedural drama that could it's just in
space and it could be literally any
procedural drama just copy and paste it
into it and that's it doesn't feel
special to me there is no heart there's
no soul it's utopian BS
it's talking about the the most
difficult problems in humanity it raises
things like racism sexism all these
things they the the the Star Trek
tackles it did tackle those but it
tackled them in like an ultra simplistic
way if if we want a cool Sci-Fi series
that is a procedural drama kind of setup
I'm watching a Stargate
but that's that's a different argument
um a Star Wars Star Trek just I'm going
I want Stargate thank you and but Star
Wars is so slow it makes Lord of the
Rings look high fast-paced and excited
it's just it's so slow right earlier
until you admit that the last episode of
Mandalorian was crap was was just
perfectly conceived besides the
overnight bird thing the overnight bird
thing that that that that that time wise
but but time in Star Wars has never made
sense that's that's where it is not
really truly a science fantasy it's a
space fantasy but that's where you
compare it's more comparable to Lord of
the Rings than it is Star Trek in many
ways because it is this sprawling tale
that that expands to more than just oh
what's Earth doing and what's Earth
thinking and how are we gonna do this
that's just one small my my new detail
of Star Wars talk about Nuance there's a
Galaxy to explore and we have explored
so much of it but we always find the way
back in Tatooine which is aggravating so
oh yeah it's always on time so the one
last point on on montalore I swear to
God if they say this is the way one more
time my TV you'll see my TV fly over you
where you live because I will just throw
the [__] this is the way it's not the
answer to every question what's you want
for tea this is the way no what you want
for tea and go I'll have chicken and
it's just
it's not the answer to every question
it's not the bloody way it's not
this is the way I have spoken yeah
whatever that one
is the way what's the best way to get to
Tatooine this is the way no I'm asking
you the question it's just for the love
of God just answer the question it's not
the answer in this country I always take
the piss because in Telford I don't know
if it's like this the rest of England
but the Intel for you seem to be really
bad that everyone if you say all right
mate the answer is all right mate you
don't answer the question you don't
actually answer if you're all right or
not if you say all right the answer is
all right for mandalorians this is the
way the answer is this is the way it's
just you're just changing [__] [__]
I'm sorry well what what was it was it
Matt that said it I I in our little
group messages I don't I don't remember
what's the difference between this is
the way in Jaffa Curry
no it's exactly the same yeah and Jaffa
cream means nothing as well to me decree
does have meaning I'm always trying to
figure out exactly what it meant I'm
like it's attention or like Yoo-hoo as
Jack says oh it's like like look at me
pay attention to a bunch of things yeah
um I think so the the the the
um this is the way is the best part of
the Mandalorian series because it
creates some identity I would oh God
constantly highlighted everything then I
would agree with that except that they
use it constantly and and but it's never
bothered but you know why they use it
constantly Jay it's a cold because
they're bored and they can't because
this is the way
um that's perfect honestly in the last
episode though because it was boring me
to death and the logic of it was
starting to get me a bit irritated and I
like the Mandalorian I've really enjoyed
it
this is the way we're starting to get on
my tits and by the end of the series I
was there honestly I was scratching at
the setting on say it one more time I
[__] day and and then they did
kill
um he's another way do you know the way
that's that Bob Ramirez are putting
Knuckles above it and if y'all haven't
seen Uganda Knuckles it's the it's the
dumbest video ever it's not gonna y'all
don't like it at all but it's you know
Knuckles from chronic yeah it's a fact I
know the meme you know the way yeah do
you know the way
I thought the words at this point I know
the weather to this boat too that's
where I actually took a break real quick
I was like Star Trek talk I gotta get
out I I feel this argument may continue
um beyond that I mean the old Star Wars
track argument has continued for many
years
um because um Star Trek is bad so
um what we want we won't put Stargate
into the discussion because yet
Stargate is better so
um that that is the way what is the way
Stargate Stargate so for the love of God
Amazon bring it back right so guys I am
going to go and put my head in a bucket
of ice water and see if that'll shift
this headache even though it seems to be
shifting a little bit actually
um take a video and do ALS bucket ice
challenge just 2.0 yeah have you ever
seen the guy that did that he froze the
whole bucket and then tipped on his head
and it crushed his skull and killed him
I can imagine it
yeah Darwinism it is best that and like
what did he think was gonna happen idiot
anyway
um thank you guys for coming on and
thanks everybody that's got in the
comments you've been absolute Legends as
always
um
as I said we've got a few exciting
things coming up Matt's going to sleep
so we won't we won't bother him I get
tired at this time every I don't know
what it is literally as soon as it's
like this time I just like my age I want
to go to bed at nine o'clock
do you guys ever like get really tied at
like half a this is how it's gonna do
this because Harris doesn't get tired
he's just like look at him he's the 19
child really
um but you get like tied about half
eight and then when you try to go to bed
at 10 you can't sleep
I wish I got a bit of our fake
uh but anyway
I wish I had that energy I'd take naps
during the day then stay up to two I'm
bad
yeah I know I'm gonna say this is the
way to my colleagues
for a reason obviously create people
um
anyway guys put some hot water yeah I've
got um a bag thing and I had it on my
head before but then I thought I had an
hour I thought it was four o'clock
um so about 10 to I was I was going to
bed I was going to go put my head thing
I'm back in the head and just and go
close my eyes for 10 minutes and I know
it will shift it and I got a message off
Matt going where are you and I'm like
it's only four o'clock I'm I'm gonna go
for a nap for a little bit I'm like no
[Music]
that's green yeah
bloody this is the way oh no it isn't
good and um yeah
Galactica mini series over the weekend
got it so good
so so good all right thank you guys so
much
um as always you've been absolutely
legendary I have to just waffle for two
seconds while I find the end screen bit
which I found waffle waffle we will be
back next week you know at some point
we'll do that beta movie uh B-movie
video we said but then something about
Stargate will happen again or Star Trek
or something else
um
but we will see thank you so so much
guys we will see you next week
um as always
say bye
bye see ya
foreign
[Music]